the right of property is the guardian of
every other right and to deprive a
people of this is in fact to deprive
them of their liberty so Arthur Lee of
Virginia declared in words as relevant
today as they were during the American
Founding hello I'm congressman mike
pence I'm from Indiana and it is my
honor to welcome you to this online Town
Hall sponsored by hillsdale college on
the topic of economic liberty and the
Constitution you know honor is what
allows us to do what's right despite the
cost even greater honor is required to
do what's right in the face of superior
power but the greatest honor is to stand
strong even if it means standing alone
this has been the long fight of
Hillsdale College standing then and now
for the proposition that all men are
created equal Hillsdale has stood for
ideas that as Reagan said came from the
heart of a great nation ideas that rose
in a time of unprecedented stress and
genius and ideas and principles that
since the American Founding have kept
this country whole prosperous safe and
free having taken its stand in the
heartland for a century and a half
Hillsdale now brings that tradition here
to the kirby center in washington DC
where statesmanship is taught as an art
it's a genuine honor for me to address
you today senator robert taft wrote
liberty has been the key to our progress
in the past and is the key to our
progress in the future if we can
preserve Liberty in all its essentials
there's no limit to the future of the
American people in a time when if we
witness the unprecedented growth of
government spending mandates regulation
and the attendant burden of deficits and
debt how do we as americans choose
Liberty once again how do we ensure that
our children will live as citizens not
subjects and how does the Constitution
of the United States serve as a vanguard
of our liberty and property even today
here with your participation and your
questions later we'll explore all these
issues to begin we'll hear how our
economic Liberty has been diminished
from dr. Paul Marino the GRU [ __ ] chair
of constitutional history at Hillsdale
College dr. marina will explain how
economic
Liberty was revered by our founding
fathers they enshrined its principles in
the Constitution a hundred years ago
those tenants were attacked by
progressives who saw property rights as
the protection of special interests and
our Constitution structure as an
impediment progress as they defined it
later we'll hear how our economic
Liberty can be restored from the
incomparable dr. Larry Arn president of
Hillsdale College dr. Arnn will
challenge us to think more to study more
and to understand how economic liberty
can be restored as decisively as it's
been lost with greater citizen
understanding and vigilant defense of
the principles of the Declaration and
the Constitution to choose Liberty we
must first understand it is our
birthright as Americans we must prepare
ourselves to defend it at our dinner
tables over backyard fences in
classrooms coffee clubs and in the
public debate and there is an urgency to
this task in recent times assaults on
our economic Liberty have become a
routine part of the modern welfare state
until the advent of the new majority in
Congress borrowing spending bailouts and
takeovers had become a staple of
governance under both political parties
whether it be the mandate that Americans
purchase health insurance the
nationalization of auto manufacturers
and banks the distortion of the laws of
bankruptcy the stimulus the excesses of
Freddie and Fannie we are awash in
policies that reveal a deep erosion of
constitutional protections coming from
people in both the executive and
legislative branches who seemed to
disparage and deny the concept of
economic flourishing that was envisioned
by our founders the appointment of czars
administrators without proper Senate
confirmation armed with pretext for the
environment to regulate order to
restrain a multitude of economic
enterprises all of which infringe upon
our economic Liberty or even more
examples and these excesses even extend
to the view of Taxation as well along
with the predictable class warfare
rhetoric in his recent budget speech
this week Americans heard our president
refer to efforts to preserve low tax
rates as quote spending in the tax code
the president described tax relief and
tax deductions as quote tax expenditures
adding that the tax code is quote loaded
up with spending on things like itemized
deductions taxing is now spending this
Washington view of taxation of property
assumes that all wealth belongs to the
government and when the government is
denied access to that some of the well
that constitutes spending in the tax
code this view of property I would
submit the role of government in the
history of abuses I just described is it
odds with the principles enshrined in
the Constitution of the United States
while the founders considered limited
government to be the vanguard of our
Liberty due to the influence of
progresses beginning more than a century
ago many Americans have lost sight of
this simple truth as you will hear today
the founders believed that human nature
was fixed in flawed and instituted a
strong but limited government to protect
natural rights progressives believed
that human nature was malleable and
perfectible and instituted government by
experts and administrators designed to
adapt to contemporary circumstances and
protect collective rights the founders
of this nation saw the protection of
property as the first object of
government in his famous essay on the
topic the father of our Constitution
James Madison described property as
follows quote a man's land or
merchandise or money but also quote he
said a man has property in his opinions
and the free communication of them his
religious opinions and in the profession
and practice dictated by them and in the
safety and liberty of his person in a
word he said as a man is said to have a
right to his property he may be equally
said to have a property in his rights
Madison understood that the genesis of
property rightly understood was
immaterial it was ideas future hope
willingness to risk and a love of
improving nature of turning the
wasteland into a garden and Madison
believed and I quote where an excess of
power prevails property of know so
is duly respected no man is safe in his
opinions his person his faculties or his
possessions put more bluntly he
concluded if there be a government then
which prides itself in maintaining the
inviolability of property yet directly
violates the property which individuals
have such a government is not a pattern
for the United States the pattern of
government for this nation can be found
in the Constitution of the United States
the Constitution given life by the
luminous and passionate declaration of
independence is terse sober and specific
it is not a fluctuating and inconstant
document it is not a collection of
suggestions the purpose of which was to
stimulate debate in the future
progressives tell us that even the
framers themselves could not reach an
agreement in its regard but they did
agree upon it they wrote it down they
signed it and they live by it it's words
are unchanging and unchangeable except
as planned by careful amendment any
citizen aspiring to choose Liberty
should regard the Constitution and the
Declaration as the essence of American
governance and they should be
preoccupied with adherence to its
principles these documents should be on
their mind all the time they should be
the prism through which the light of all
questions of governance pass though we
have sometimes gradually sometimes
radically moved away from this we could
move back to it again the Constitution
was designed to preserve Liberty it
established a just government with
specific enumerated powers checks and
balances all designed to restrain
government excess and the abuse of power
that might intrude upon the property of
the American people while the Bill of
Rights contains specific restraints on
the power of the national government the
pattern of limited government
encompasses the Republic as ordain and
establish and it remains the vanguard of
our liberties today the protections of
property are not only written in the
amendments they are interwoven
throughout the document itself
and enshrine in the principles of
limited government a unique opportunity
to advance our economic Liberty in
particular I would submit can be found
in advancing the constitutional
principle of federalism to confront the
fiscal crisis facing our country it will
not be sufficient to simply reduce
federal government spending we must also
use the resources in the Constitution to
permanently reduce the size and scope of
the federal government by recognizing
the distinction between the powers
granted the federal government and those
reserved to the states into the people
in his first inaugural address President
Reagan reminded the American people that
quote the federal government did not
create the states the states created the
federal government one year later
President Reagan came to Indiana to
address the issue of federalism before a
joint session of our state General
Assembly he used that Hoosier backdrop
to announce a new presidential
commission on federalism which he called
the new phase of the great American
experiment as a start he offered to
return 40 federal programs and the
revenues associated with them back to
the States the Commission and its work
fell flat but President Reagan was right
30 years ago and he's more right today
for his efforts to succeed it would have
required an unprecedented level of
leadership rising at the state and local
level which is exactly what's happening
today perhaps providentially the
leadership and initiative the President
Reagan called for 30 years ago is
emerging in states across the country
consider the courageous stands that
governors in new jersey Wisconsin Ohio
and Indiana are taking on behalf of
fiscal discipline and reform or the
actions taken by States rejecting the
individual mandate in Obamacare and
opposing the imposition of cap and trade
or those responding to inaction by the
federal government on illegal
immigration or traditional marriage in
state after state we find unprecedented
leadership and initiative that is
changing the dynamics of our national
debate with so many states taking a
stand in so many different ways for
their constitutional significance it's
clear that this is no temporary trend in
American
politics we are witnessing the rise of
the states to restore limited government
we not only must take notice of this new
dynamic we must encourage it we must
support those who fight within the
federal system and assist those leaders
at the state level who are leading the
fight from without the states were our
past they were forged from the
wilderness the states hold the promise
of the future and I believe if there's
to be a rebirth of constitutional
governance in America it will come from
the state or not at all these are
challenging times in the life of this
still young nation what might our
forbearers say to us knowing what they
knew and having done what they did I
have no doubt that they would tell us to
channel our passions simply speak the
truth and do what's right slowly and
with resolution to work calmly steadily
and without animus or fear to be like a
rock and the tide to let the water
tumble about us to be firm and unashamed
in our love of country I believe they
would encourage us foremost to cling to
first principles never waver in our
belief in the genius of the American
Founding or the goodness of the American
people and this I know we are doing by
joining us today for this online town
hall meeting you confirm my belief that
a passion for liberty and the principles
of the American Founding is awakening in
the hearts and minds of millions of
Americans by seizing this opportunity to
understand how we arrived at this point
to embrace the principles that will
bring us back you confirm everything I
believe about these times you know I see
Americans today like those in
Philadelphia in 1776 danger all around
but a fresh chapter ready to begin
uncorrupted with great possibilities and
inexplicably perhaps miraculously the
way is clearing ahead I've never doubted
that Providence can appear in history
like the Sun emerging from behind the
clouds if only as a reward for adherence
to first principles as Winston Churchill
said before Congress in 1941 quote
he must indeed have a blind soul who
cannot see some great purpose and design
be worked out here below of which we
have the honor to be the faithful
servants you are the faithful servants
of Liberty today thank you for the
privilege of addressing you thank you
for supporting the important work of the
kirby center and hillsdale college may
god bless you all